de qué se trata y de dónde sale la idea
de una ley o una eventual ley sobre
gestión menstrual
buenas noches así es hoy estuvimos en el
congreso de la nación debatiendo sobre
la necesidad y la importancia de que
argentina pueda tener una ley de gestión
menstrual esto es lo venimos trabajando
de hace muchísimos años y ahora está
tomando cada vez mayor visibilidad y
nuestra nuestra intención es poder
trabajar y distribuir y hacer que sean
accesibles los productos de gestión
menstrual porque en argentina tenemos
alrededor de 12 millones de mujeres
adolescentes niñas personas trans y no
binarias que destruyan y realmente el
costo que se utiliza de gasto para
productos es muy elevado y es muy alto y
hemos detectado que en la población
sobre todo más vulnerada de los sectores
populares se hace muy difícil la compra
de elementos para gestionar la
menstruación así que de esta manera lo
venimos trabajando como bien dijeron
activistas movimientos populares
el poder ejecutivo de la nación
legisladores tanto la cámara de
senadores como la de diputados y
diputadas para poder alcanzar una ley
que lo que nos permita es una
distribución de estos productos o que
sean mucho más baratos que sean más
fáciles de acceder porque bueno
contemplamos que hay una brecha y una
desigualdad entre las mujeres y las
diversidades las personas más grandes y
que esta brecha de alguna manera tenemos
que empezar a cortarla en materia
económica como beneficiaría a esto a las
personas maestro antes
y es lo que estamos pensando es la
posibilidad de la distribución gratuita
en algunos sectores o en escuelas
públicas sobre todo también detectando
que la mayor cantidad de niñas de los
sectores escolares muchas veces dejan de
asistir a la escuela cuando están
mezclando porque no tienen la
posibilidad de comprar toallitas
tampones y distintos elementos
a veces lo sustentable no las toallitas
de tela así que por eso es que estamos
trabajando para nuestra realidad está
esta ley
una mayor cantidad de programas o
políticas del estado para abordar esta
situación que realmente en algunos
sectores se hace completamente difícil y
costosa onerosa estamos hablando de más
de 12 millones de personas es un número
muy significativo por lo tanto el estado
debe intervenir debe generar políticas
públicas y en todo caso también
sancionar una ley que lo que permita es
la distribución y el acceso a estos
productos y además también la parte de
la educación no poder como bien decía
y poder sacar ese tabú y empezar a
tratar este tema empezará a conversarlo
empezará a
no
sea un tema que se pueda conversar
señora gómez de sancionarse cree que
pueda sentar un precedente en otros
países de la región
y si por supuesto va a sentar un
precedente como lo ha sido la aprobación
de la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo a ustedes bien saben que
argentina ha sido pionera en este y en
otros temas en materia de derechos
humanos y entendemos también que de
aprobarse también estaríamos comentando
todo lo que tiene que ver con la
autogestión y además trabajar
fuertemente lo que significa el impacto
ambiental
ya que producimos
una toallita
lamento interrumpir la pero tenemos muy
poco tiempo muchas gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en france 24